so when can we expect you back about
that so people need a king no they
already have one that's funny it's time
for me to be Who I am rather than who
I'm supposed to be but you you're a
leader that's what you are you know it
make a lot of changes around here hmm
I'm counting on it Your Majesty what
will you do I'm not sure the first time
in a thousand years I have no path I do
have a ride though move it or lose it as
guardians of the galaxy back together
again oh where to first
hey just so you know this is my ship
still I'm in charge I know I know of
course you are
of course see you say of course but then
you touch the map it makes you think
that maybe you didn't realize I was in
charge it quit you that's your own well
here it is in there okay I'm merely
trying to be of service in this system
quill that's what I said I should fight
one another from the honor of leadership
sounds fair
it's not necessary it's not okay
I got some blasters unless you guys want
to use knives oh yes please use knives
no not there should be no knifing one
another everybody knows who's in charge
me yes however one is Charlie I've got a
lot of requests to do a video for Thor
for love and thunder so I'll explain
what the plot of that movie is they
explained a lot of it during the big
Marvel phase four panel so we'll break
it all down we're doing that Avengers
endgame blu-ray giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best Thor for theory on the video I
just broke this down top-10 style so
starting with number 10 Thor 4 is now
going to take place before guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 Thor 4 is tail end
Marvel phase 4 timeline / this schedule
and guardians is now confirmed Marvel
phase 5 just because James Gunn is going to be busy doing Suicide Squad before he
does guardians of the galaxy vol 3 so
very brief Guardians cameo at the
beginning of Thor 4 just for the sake of
continuity because Thor is off on their
ship as guardians of the galaxy again /
that scene at the end of endgame but now
Thor may or may not cameo in guardians 3
the movie is going to pick up a little
while after the events of Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness for
important multiverse reasons I'll
explain in a second but it's hitting
theaters November 2021 the last two Thor
films have been November films so that's
not a really big surprise they haven't
confirmed whether or not there'll be a
Loki cameo from the alternate universe
Loki with the tesseract from Avengers
endgame if he's going to crossover because the movie is happening after they do the
Loki TV series with that character if it
wasn't clear the Loki of the Loki TV
series that Tom Hiddleston is playing is
the tesseract Loki that we saw escaped
in Avengers endgame and create this
branch timeline so he's alternate
universe Loki now who's still alive in
present day they
didn't say who the main villain is going
to be but don't be surprised if they
also use a villain from the multiverse
that's why the Doctor Strange movie is
going to be so important because even
though the multiverse already exists
there's a lot of casual audience members
that don't really know how it works and
that's what they're getting into
during the Doctor Strange multiverse
movie multiverse is also important for
the Mighty Thor plot that they're doing
from the comics so 9 the plot of the
movie is based as you would probably
assumed on Jason Aaron's Mighty Thor run
from the past few years during that
story Jane Foster becomes an alternate
version of Thor when comic book Mjolnir
from the 6-1-6 comic book universe deems
her worthy the reason why the hammer
deems her worthy is really important -
because it has a lot to do with what the
Marvel Comics were doing with the main
version of Thor in the wake of original
sin in secret Wars what they did is when
he became unworthy of the hammer he
stopped calling himself Thor and just
called himself odin son and they used
the Thor name is more of a title that
you could pass around instead of just a
regular name like my name is Charlie you
don't pass that around unless I have a
son and then named him charlie once
regular Thor couldn't lift the hammer
anymore
the hammer in the comics is alive it has
a sentience so the hammer knows that
Asgard in the nine realms always needs a
Thor to protect it to wield it so when
our main version of Thor becomes
unworthy the hammer selects another Thor
to replace him in the replacement just
winds up being Jane Foster who slowly
dying of cancer they did not say if
they're going to do the cancer plot from
the comics like if our Jane Foster
Natalie Portman is going to wind up having
cancer at the beginning of the movie but
number 8 as you probably suspected MCU
Thor is still worthy of the hammer at
the end of Avengers endgame so that
creates some problems they'll have to
change the comics quite a bit Tycho YTD
is writing the script for the movie and
directing just like he did the script
for Thor Ragnarok and directed in that
movie was a mash-up of Planet Hulk gore
the god butcher Angela in comic book
hella so the actual plot of Thor 4 will
be a remix of Mighty Thor with a bunch
of other deep cuts from the classic Thor
comics 7 Valkyrie is still going to be king
of Asgard during the movie and going
forward into Marvel phase 5 they
revealed that she'll also select a queen
to join her on the throne noob Asgard is
still going to be on earth in Norway but
because
all those as guardians were unsnapped
orb lit back by the hope during endgame
now there are double what there were
before still a fraction of their former
population before hella and Thanos then
killed a bunch of them the old-fashioned
way but the actual job of being king of
Asgard will just be a much bigger deal
with that many more subjects to handle
six as you probably assumed natalie
portman is returning as Jane Foster is a
main character during the movie even
though she was briefly in Avengers
endgame this is actually kind of funny
her cameo the reality stone scene was
actually taken from a deleted scene in
thor ragnarok that they just added
rocket to Natalie Portman never set foot
on the set of Avengers end game and
never really had anything to do with it
after Thor the dark world came out she
did pretty much everything she could to
get people to forget she was ever in a
Thor movie during Avengers age of Ultron
they sort of relegated her off into the
distance towards like oh she's off
studying science and Asgardian
technology somewhere safe but in fact to
Thor the dark world heralded as one of
the weakest MCU scripts by the fandom
the same people who wrote Avengers
infinity war in Avengers end game wrote
Thor the dark world Markus and McFeely
they also wrote all the Captain America
movies so part of the reason why they
used all that Thor the dark world stuff
during Avengers end game was to one kind
of make fun of themselves for their own
bad script but to to retcon a lot of
those things with new scenes like all
the Frigga stuff to make it seem like a
much better movie
in retrospect just a really funny side
detail but v in order for Thor for to
make Jane Foster become an alternate
version of Thor Taika Waititi said
during the movie she will be referred to
as Mighty Thor when she's in Thor form
she'll have to wield a version of
Mjolnir she has to be deemed worthy by a
version of the hammer and that only
works when you have Mjolnir Stormbreaker
which regular thor still has right now
doesn't have a worthiness enchantment on
it so anyone who's physically strong
enough can pick it up that's why Thanos
is able to lift Stormbreaker and use it
against Thor during their big fight but
here's the thing at the end of Avengers
endgame Captain America casually takes
Mjolnir back to Thor the dark world so
they don't have a version of Mjolnir in
present day because hella blew that one
up at the beginning of Thor Ragnarok the
whole plot of Thor 4 rests on that
having a version
that hammer so for early speculation
best theory is is that because the movie
is happening at the tail in the Marvel
phase for after the events of Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness
that though used the multiverse to get
themselves another version of Mjolnir
for Jane Foster to wield remember
multiverse is also important for
involving the alternate version of Loki
with the tesseract because wouldn't it
be weird to have a Thor film with no
Loki cameo they did the exact same thing
with Thor's hammer after Secret Wars you
have hundreds of different versions of
Thor and Secret Wars running around when
they fixed everything ultimate Thor's
hammer which coincidentally looks just
like MCU Stormbreaker winds up in the
6-1-6 universe waiting till another
person came along to pick it up and
become another alternate version of Thor
that version of Thor that wielded
ultimate Thor's hammer was called the
war Thor he was different from the Jane
Foster Mighty Thor but it's the
multiverse Hammer explainer that matters
three that way you can have two versions
of Thor in the same movie one our
regular Thor with storm breaker and a
Mighty Thor Jane Foster without having
to make normal Thor unworthy again and
without having to end him at the
beginning of the movie your next big
question I know is if Thor's alive and
he still has Stormbreaker then why did
they need another version of Thor what's
the whole point of this well the reason
is probably because Asgard must always
have a Thor and at the beginning of
Avengers endgame our main version of
Thor says he's setting off to
intergalactic adventures across the
universe so he won't be around to help
them out but you say Charlie
Stormbreaker can open Bifrost bridges
teleporting Thor instantly across the
universe anywhere it wants to go why is
availability a problem if Thor can go
anywhere in an instant so number two
next early speculation early theory is
that he'll wind up giving Stormbreaker
to beta ray bill after they introduced
the character because beta ray bills
hammer in the comics is called
Stormbreaker beta ray bill the character
was supposed to debut during thor
ragnarok they shot footage with him for
the contest of Champions the big arena
fights then decided at the last minute
to cut him from the film and just save
him for a proper story in a future Thor
film when he could be a bigger character
Thor 4 is the perfect opportunity to
introduce him in before
they confirmed when the movie was
actually supposed to happen I'd assume
naturally that they'd introduce and
during guardians of the galaxy vol 3
because he's such a weird character he's
also perfect for the guardians of the
galaxy movies he even joined a version
of the Guardians team recently in the
comics so that's how you take away main
Thor's instant transmission ability but
number one probably biggest question you
have I know is is what's going to happen to
main Thor in Jane Foster Mighty Thor
after Thor for most likely scenario is
that depending on what kind of contract
natalie portman signs she'll continue to
cameo as Jane Foster Thor every once in
a while in future MCU movies in the
background like a couple scenes here and
there in the next Avengers movie but not
really is a huge main character like
Chris Hemsworth
Thor has been main Thor will either
probably wind up sacrificing himself
like he did in the comics during war of
the realms as a way to sort of ice him
for a little while till the next
Avengers movie or continue off exploring
the universe into Marvel phase 5 like
look at what I found in this corner of
the universe there's a big creature
calling itself Galactus so post all your
Thor for theories in the comments below
there's a d23 Marvel panel happening in
a couple weeks we'll probably get some
more details about what's going on
during Marvel phase four or Marvel phase
5 so I will do videos for all that stuff
whatever they wind up dropping but I'm
also working on more Avengers endgame
deleted scenes in Marvel phase four
videos like Fantastic Four and more
x-men stuff so leave all your video
requests in the comments below
but I'll name a giveaway winner when I
post that next Marvel video click here
for my shang-chi teaser video and iron
man Easter eggs and click here for that
brand new Deadpool 3 Marvel phase 5 teaser
thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome maximum effort!